[Applause]
welcome to another monumental monday you
marvelous maniacs it's the start of our
first halloween week-long extravaganza
as you can see i am in costume
i came tonight as jesse waters
you can tell i'm him from the tweezed
eyebrows and inflated self-esteem
[Laughter]
it's so convincing that on my way to
work i was pelted with wet garbage
and that was from his mother
but before we get to the news it's time
for a very special halloween episode of
our favorite new sitcom
[Music]
uh
[Music]
laughs tonight's episode in human
resources
well i'm sure you're aware of all the
horrific things that have been happening
around the gutfeld offices and we in
human resources we cannot tolerate death
and dismemberment in the workplace what
does this have to do with me dude you're
wasting my time i got two hit shows
what's the deal here let me refresh your
memory
oh
my god
what's wrong oh my god you all right
nothing i
just i don't know i'm seeing things yeah
you've been working really hard yeah
thirsty you probably need something to
drink if you're dehydrated
[Music]
we did that on a limited budget
i can't believe schwimmer did not take
that role
all right to the news
on thursday actor and gun control
activist alec baldwin accidentally
killed a cinematographer on the set of
the western he was filming in new mexico
as the news dribbles out we see many
things that went wrong
now we hear that the gun actually had
been used for target practice by the
so-called expert yikes and it may have
had live ammo in it double yikes and
that it was pointed at a person triple
yikes that's a huge no-no and one of the
most basic tenets of gun safety you
don't have to be an nra member to know
that the firearm also wasn't checked
each step of the way from hand off to
hand off
all of these tragic errors are based on
carelessness inexperience and lack of
safety protocols they might as well put
hunter biden in charge of the medicine
cabinet
now it could be they were in a hurry to
save money it could be they were cutting
corners either way it was a highly
preventable screw-up having an expert on
gun safety would have changed that it
seems at least to me that's what was
lacking but where do those experts come
from
i would say the nra but you might as
well say ira if you're telling that to
hollywood gun control activists they'd
rather take gun training from charlie
sheen in a hot tub full of mayonnaise
so fat chance anyone from the nra would
be invited to a movie set where baldwin
was the producer cat would have a better
chance guest hosting special reports
[Laughter]
one day
and so we find another instance where
the prison of two ideas creates problems
if there was an nra person on set this
would never have happened but no one in
charge would do that because in the
prison of two ideas gun control good
nra evil and that dictates that you're
either a gun control activist like
baldwin or you're an evil gun owner like
me and that excludes real expertise if
the two prison idea didn't exist the set
would have benefited from the nra's
hardcore focus on safety and it would
have saved a life it's like a homophobe
not asking his gay neighbor who's an
interior designer to help him decorate
his apartment
in the long run he's only hurting
himself
instead of getting laid all the time
girls are going to take one look at his
neon budweiser sign and shag rug and say
sorry guy enjoy your hand
we still don't know what truly happened
but it's becoming clearer and clearer
perhaps the people who work in the world
of make-believe want nothing to do with
reality's true experts anti-gun
advocates hate gun advocates because of
a projection of their own insecurities
it's not that they don't trust gun
people with guns is that they don't
trust themselves with guns therefore it
should not exist at all
last week we talked about a segregated
dorm of women and trans people who were
upset when cisnormative i.e straight
repairmen came to install new radiators
for their rooms to anticipate an ohio
winter
you think there's nothing worse than a
male or female freezing their balls off
but no
it's straight men trying to help you
stay warm
the dormies didn't want their world
infringed by another different world
they felt unsafe with a straight man in
their midst
what would they have preferred do the
work themselves
you see that's like handling a gun on a
set with no expert you see it's all the
same that if you segregate your world
based on ideas or identities you lose
out on the experience the wisdom and the
expertise of the very groups that you're
avoiding here's a chart
the first one shows the prison of two
ideas you see there is no information
sharing the second one shows them
overlapping that's how wisdom in
know-how spreads it's pretty simple
stuff i came up with that chart myself
but this simple phenomenon is now being
prevented as a consequence of the
elitist thirst for separation and
conflict and it's happening everywhere
from campus housing to hollywood there
are millions of amazing people who know
how to deliver cargo repair trucks build
bridges and handle guns but what if
they're straight
or trump supporters or religious or meat
eaters or they put pineapple on their
pizza
stop it emily love it it's the baby in
the bath water you divorce yourself from
different people and you divorce
yourself from their invaluable
assistance and you end up clueless and
stupid
meaning a college student
just the way the professional sports
world benefited from desegregating the
set of baldwin's movie could have
benefited from an nra's members
experience and knowledge i'm sure the
nra would have gladly volunteered an
expert to oversee safety protocols you
probably could have found a liberal one
too
but no one thought of that because nra
bad gun control good it's unfortunate a
tragedy like this had to happen before
maybe somebody on a movie set says sure
he voted for trump but he can clean his
ar-15 blindfolded
but i prefer to live in a world where
people know how to control the guns they
have rather than people having guns and
have no control at all hiring a gun
lover would have threatened their safe
space but without them it became a
deadly one so maybe if you're gonna film
using real guns
reconsider your anti-gun ideology allow
real experts to be involved so you can
expertly shoot movies and not colleagues
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
if she were a salad dressing it would be
dreamy italian
outnumbered co-host emily cabano
he wears red berets and rescues feline
sprays new york city republican mayoral
candidate curtis sliwa
this halloween we asked it to egg her
because she needs the protein foxy's
contributor cat tip
and a small step for tyrus is one giant
leap for mankind my massive sidekick in
the nwa world television champion
iris
[Applause]
tires i go to you first because you are
on a lot of movie sets yes some with
permission some without uh just kidding
you know
uh you make a lot of great points in
your monologue but
it's actually lower than that yeah this
is about elitism and greed
which ended the result of
of unfortunate death the working
conditions for the crew were so poor
that they walked offset
which means and that goes to and i've
been on some
we'll call them b
movies okay whether it's a small budget
or whatever but usually the guys on
small budget movies work their ass off
because they want to be big budget
movies one day and everything with guns
and stunts is all about procedure
routine repetition it's every time i was
in a scene with a gun one take hand it
back he checks it when he hands it back
he puts it on the table then they check
it again it comes back then he yells to
the group cold or hot letting you know
what what the situation with the gun is
when you
get to the point and this is alec
baldwin i'm assuming he's successful
he's producing this movie
he's got people giving him loans and
investing
and you're starving out and having the
people that you rely on
behind the scenes the stunt workers the
coordinators the seconds the thirds the
guys you never see except a little bit
on if you stay on the credit looking for
an extra part of a movie he didn't want
to pay them or give them a decent place
to sleep at night and they were doing
this old trick where they'd ask him to
take a two hour lunch so they could work
a 15-hour day which is against all the
sag rules so lo and behold he
then they walk off right and what does
the liberal elitist do i'll replace them
with locals non-union no non-union guys
which that's not a fair shot at them but
when you cross over even if on the best
situation if they told me right now hey
tyra it's not working out shalou's going
to take over from right here in my
earpiece and as shalou walks in and goes
what were you saying i'm going to say
yourself and walk out
curtis what do you make of this
what a hot mess yeah yes
that's how they describe me
now i know alec baldwin i've had a great
relationship with alec and all of his
brothers through all the years because
you know they're local yeah long island
guys they've all succeeded in different
capacities some of them that's true
billy not so much look and ups downs all
around so right
but i'll tell you this
having been shot with a gun five times
38 special
every time i see a gun it's got to be
check check double check
because it brings back nightmares to me
i was fortunate enough to survive a hit
man you know from the gambinos and the
gotti's
but that that one piece that you're
holding in your hand can do so much
damage and you would think there would
be someone on the set right nra train
certified what do they call that the
eagle scouting uh i think uh
gun seminar that they give and just have
them check check double check triple
check quadruple check because that kills
that means yeah but there's no thought
process today especially i think to
tyrus's point about the cost cutting
that takes over and then all this all
these protocols go away emily you're our
legal eagle
usually you say i don't believe that
you're an attorney this is an
improvement i feel like i've been
promoted
i am going to not for long
you know
never mind
uh where do you see this going legally
young lady well to respond to your
monologue a gun safety group came out
and said exactly that they said the
teachable moment here is that when a
hollywood actor lectures you about gun
control they don't have a clue what
they're talking about because safety is
no accident and that goes exactly into
what you're saying in the protocols
legally i think we see an unfortunate
trend here that on this particular set
there was concern after concern raised
that the assistant director dave halls
was ignoring all of that protocol and
procedure in addition to the egregious
situation that was happening with all
the other stuff but specifically in the
realm of firearms and pyrotechnics there
were there were complaints that were
made and also on prior sets so this guy
has a history of ignoring safety
protocols that other people around him
have raised the pyrotechnic technicians
and prop masters have raised and to your
point it might just land in the civil
bucket but in 2012 a woman named sarah
jones who was a camera assistant was
killed by a freight train in a stunt in
new york state and the assistant
director was put on probation for 10
years but the director was criminally
charged with involuntary manslaughter
and he served a year in prison oh wow
and the way that i see this coming out
you know note with no with all homage to
halloween is that heads are going to
roll um interesting catch you're
familiar with firearms
yeah that's all i have to say
um is it
kind of hypocritical for anti-gun actors
to be shooting guns in movies in the
first place because it really because
they treat them as make-believe as
opposed to as respecting the weapon like
i always go to the point where when
they're firing a gun sideways which
nobody does
yeah well that that's i guess but you do
a lot of stuff in the movies that you
just just like how if i say something
and it ends up you know striking a nerve
i just say i was just kidding
that's how they that's how they probably
i've been defending a lot of movies i
made
uh i know 90s right
yeah but even you didn't fire your gun
coordinator no i didn't but those stunts
were really crazy
i landed on that horse every time it's
just one of those things where people
talk you know about work environment
hostile work environmental you know say
this hospital
look i don't think a work environment is
more hostile
than one where there's as you mentioned
repeated warnings if we're having all
these accidents with lethal weapons can
we maybe fix this and they're just
rushing like like what could be more
important than that yeah i would think
nothing so it's obviously a really
really really sad situation and um it's
one of those lessons like oh we can
learn from something from this but it's
also disheartening to know this is
something that needs to be learned
exactly no they could have again if they
if they
welcome wisdom from the people they hate
right that's the whole that's the lesson
here and i'm always trying to teach
lessons
because i'm the hero hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else